welcome to the show friends neighbors
associates so they're really gonna do
this maybe it seems like they they're
really gonna nominate Bernie Sanders the
78 year old communist he won the New
Hampshire primary yesterday of course
there's still time for someone else to
take it but who's who's gonna step up
Warren Warren is dead in the water
Biden is dead in the water and he's just
as old and crazy anyway Chlo Bashar had
a nice third-place finish but third
place ain't gonna do it
boo the judge maybe now I have no dog in
this fight and I can't stand either of
them but from where I'm sitting it
shouldn't be much of a debate between
Buddha judge and Sanders if I'm a
Democrat the the latter is a decrepit
old communist and the former is at least
young and somewhat talented as a
politician now I've been saying this
with a with the age thing for a while
now I think this is this is really
enough itself put everything aside
afirma put everything else aside for a
moment but even his his communism aside
for a moment if you can Bernie Sanders
is currently 78 he'll be 79 come
inauguration day 83 at the end of his
first term if he had two terms he'd be
87 87 at the end of his of his two terms
the average life expectancy is 78 for
men in this country and and most of
those men who die at 78 or there abouts
don't have the most high stress high
pressure job in the country
least of all did they take on that job
at the very end of their life which is
what Bernie Sanders at nearly 80 years
old will have by the way your chance of
developing dementia at 80 is about 20%
close to 20% now a lot of people thought
that Ronald Reagan was too old and you
hear this sometimes as a justification
for electing really old people and and
we're told well they said that about
Reagan and look how that turned out
he was 77 when he left office said
Sanders will be 79 on his first day in
office
Reagan was also diagnosed with
Alzheimer's a few years after he left
office when
he was diagnosed with Alzheimer's when
he was the age that Sanders will be at
the point of the midterm elections in
2022
like I said everything else aside this
alone is enough reason to vote for
someone else someone besides him it is
lunacy to put a man that old into a
position as the most powerful person in
the world with the most high stakes job
in the world
arguably there's no justifying there's
no possible way to justify it because
you couldn't argue that this 80 year old
man with a bad heart caves already had
heart problems is really the most fit
for the job out of all the available
options on both sides of the aisle it
you you couldn't possibly make that
argument in a reasonable way and don't
give me the ageism crap okay
is it ageism for me to say that I don't
think nineteen-year-old should be
President now 19 year olds are not
allowed to be President is that a gist
no because we realized that 19 year olds
God loved him
it's no fault of their own but they
don't they're not fit for the presidency
they're just they're not old enough yet
and so we say you got to be 35 to run
for president because of the realities
of being like 19 or 20 well there are
realities about 80 year olds too and one
of them is that you aren't physically or
mentally suited for one of the most
stressful high-stakes jobs in the world
how would you feel about an 80 year old
a heart surgeon operating on you or or
an 80 year old airline captain sitting
in the cockpit and don't tell me that
well I'd be fine with it if he could do
the job no you would not be fine with it
you would not be fine with it if you're
about to take off
or if you're bored and boarding the
plane and you get a peek in the cockpit
and you see someone like that looks like
Bernie Sanders they're you you would not
be fine with that is that because you're
I just know it's because we are mortal
humans sadly and with that mortality
comes certain really unfortunate and not
very fun conditions and one of those
conditions is that your mental and
physical capacities break down with age
it happens to everybody it's not ages to
point it out it just is that I am sorry
and I don't like it either it's it's a
it's inevitable it happens to everybody
who lives long enough to experience it
and so if you tell me that well my my
grandfather is 85 and he could do the
job he's smart as a tack
or he's sharp as a tack I should say so
yeah I'm losing my mind to uh well no
offense to your grandfather but no at 85
I don't care who he is he's not fit to
be President it's it's nothing against
him it's just you're 85 you you could
literally die any minute
why are we so like why don't we want to
admit this why do people as we spend so
much time in this country denying stuff
that everybody knows is true and so even
what I'm saying right now even people
who hate Bernie Sanders I will get angry
emails from some of those people saying
how dare you this is a just I how could
you say this about old people you know
everything I'm saying is 100% true you
know what it because you've met old
people you you you know what that's like
you you understand that we're mortal
right everybody knows this why are we
pretending we don't but in any case I
why am I going on about this if the Dems
want to put this guy up for the general
that general election that's on them I
mean
Trump will be what 73 or 74 come come
the next inauguration so if if the
Democrats want to put somebody up that
makes Donald Trump look young by
comparison at 74 years old then that's
hey that's on them I'm not gonna try to
stop alright uh more to talk about I'm
gonna get away from politics and talk
about other things but first a word from
LifeLock you know one of the most
important things we can do is protect
our identity because identity theft is
is it happens every two seconds there's
a victim of identity theft which means a
criminal could be spending your money
can be applying for loans in your name
it gonna be damaging the credit that
you've worked hard to build they can
tear all that down it can be very
difficult to to get it back and that's
why it just doesn't make any sense to
not protect you think about all the
things you protect in your life you lock
your doors right well how about
protecting your identity and checking
bank statements and monitoring your
credit if you think that's enough well
it's really not because you could still
miss certain threats to your identity
you know maybe you have maybe your bank
will give you a call there's a
suspicious withdrawal or something like
that well that's that's one thing but
there are so many other avenues that
identity thieves can exploit good thing
there's LifeLock identity theft
protection life lock uses proprietary
proprietary technology to detect and
alert you to a wide range of potential
identity threats like your social
security number for sale in the dark web
for example and if you do have an issue
involving identity theft one of life
locks identity restoration specialists
will work with you to fix it of course
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but with life lock you get
identity theft protection to help
protect your devices against cyber
threats for up to 25 percent off your
first year ok it's 25% off you get all
this protection just go to LifeLock comm
slash walsh that's life lock dot-com
slash walls for 25% off life lock calm
slash Walsh ok former NBA star Dwayne
Wade went on The Ellen DeGeneres Show
this morning or should say yesterday
morning Tuesday to promote an upcoming
ESPN documentary about his life which is
called d-wade Life Unexpected if you're
interested in checking it out a cynical
person
which I have been accused of being that
at times a cynical person might expect
that Dwayne Wade was was using his sons
sexual confusion as a marketing ploy for
the film now I can't speak to his
motivations but whatever they were
he opened the interview on Ellen talking
about his 12 year old son formerly Zion
now Isaiah who recently decided to
become a girl watch this we are we are
proud when I say proud we are proud
parents of a child in the lgbtq+
community and we proud allies as well
and we take our roads and our
responsibility as parents very seriously
so when I when our child comes home with
a question when a child comes home with
the issue when a child comes home with
anything it's odd job as parents to
listen to that to give them the best
information that we can the best
feedback that we can and that doesn't
change because sexuality is now involved
in it so when's I twelve year old came
home and first died and everybody I
don't know if everyone knows originally
named Zion Zion born as a boy came home
and said hey so I want to talk to you
guys you know I think going forward I'm
ready to live my truth and I want to be
a reference that she and her I would
love for you guys to call him Izaya
now that is that's very instructive
Wade's description of this process and
his response to it is instructive and
not instructive in the way that Ellen
claims when she introduced him
introduced Wade as an exemplar of
unconditional parental love this is what
loving unconditionally means no that's
that is not what I mean by instructive
instructive in that it reveals the
confusion and ineptitude of parents who
allow radical left-wing gender theory to
invade their homes Dwayne Wade is
married to Gabrielle Union who's a
Hollywood actress and so I don't know I
mean it's it's it's it will never not be
weird to see
a normal grown man spouting this
left-wing gender theory nonsense the way
the Dwyane Wade was there he doesn't
even look comfortable doing it it
doesn't look like you really believes it
that because his wife of the Hollywood
celebrity has you know imposed this
Munoz I don't know
but Wade first explains correctly that
that you know as you heard when a child
comes home with an issue as he says it's
quote our job as parents to give them
the best information that we can the
best feedback that we can okay great now
I agree with that yes but then he tells
us that his adolescent son came home sat
them down says I need to talk to you
guys
announces that he's changing his gender
and his name and by waves telling he
accepted this self-identification
without question what happened to
providing information he just said
provide information so what information
that you provide to this child what what
feedback did you give this would seem
like a very good time for a mature adult
to give a child information about
biology information about sex
information about the nature of human
identity ok these are things that a
child doesn't understand so it'd be good
if an adult could tell them it would be
very good time for a mature adult if
only one existed in young Zayas life to
deliver a little helpful feedback and if
not information and if not feedback then
even a few probative questions would
would probably be enough to clear things
up perhaps a question like you say
you're a girl son what does that mean ok
can you tell me what what you think a
girl is and how you've come to the
conclusion that you are one that's so
it's a really reasonable question to ask
somebody anybody who makes this kind of
announcement especially your child
I'm a girl okay what do you mean by that
that's all you're asking what do you
mean by that how about just that
question could anyone object to that
question could anyone possibly object to
that follow-up what do you mean by that
tell me what you mean give me give me a
few more sentences here just to fill in
the gaps I wanna I want to understand
what you mean by that very supportive
answer right
very parental very loving not saying you
attack the child I'm not saying you you
say oh you know you disowned him or kick
him out the house or ground him not
saying that hmm it just begins with let
me understand what exactly you're saying
and what you're thinking and then we'll
try to work through this this is the
kind of question a competent parent
would ask about any significant decision
or change that a child wants to make in
their life
if a child merely wanted to let's say a
child was playing soccer and decided
that he wanted to quit soccer and wanted
to play lacrosse instead okay
there may be different seasons but
either way if your son came to you and
said that you would probably follow up
with some questions you you probably
wouldn't immediately say okay let's do
it you would want to know why did he
make this change what led up to that
decision maybe is this really that he
wants to play lacrosse or is he or is he
you know does he really actually still
want to play soccer but there are some
challenges on the soccer team maybe he
got into a fight with somebody there or
whatever he's not getting enough play
time in any so he's trying to back out
and quit and go somewhere else and some
so maybe as a parent you're gonna
depending are gonna listen and then
you're gonna provide some direction now
with something like soccer or lacrosse
there's either one is fine there's not
like there's one that's objectively
better
well lacrosse probably is objectively
better cuz soccer isn't a real sport but
still generally speaking either ones
okay even so you're gonna want to know
as a parent what's going on that the
point is
helped him sort through his own feelings
to ensure that he isn't gonna do
something he ultimately regrets because
kids have no sense of the future they
can't see beyond the nose on their face
they aren't they're thinking about that
they don't even know what they want most
of the time they don't know what they
want
so you ask a child a simple question
like what do you want in any given
situation much of the time they won't be
able to answer they don't know exactly
what they want
it is mind-boggling that every parent
would engage in this line of questioning
about a change of sports teams but some
parents won't ask any question about a
change of gender okay that's where we
are that there are parents who would
take more seriously changing sports
teams than they would changing genders
in fact it's worse than that because
Wade who just a minute prior had claimed
that a parent's job is to give the best
information which he was right about
switch courses and said that after his
son became a girl it was his Wade's job
to go in get information he went from
the leader in the household giving
information to the sort of subservient
follower taking cues from his
twelve-year-old so what Wade says it he
looked at his he looked at his son
turned daughter and says you're a leader
it's our opportunity to allow you to be
a voice except that 12-year olds are not
leaders I have news for you Dwayne Wade
your 12 year old is not a leader
no 12 year old is do you know why
because they're 12 okay 12 year olds
don't have the capacity to be a leader
of anything
maybe in a very limited capacity like on
a sports team they could be the captain
of the team okay but then there are the
capacity to be leaders of a cultural or
social movement it's not their place to
be the voice of the LGBT community or
any other community least of all is it a
father's job to be a mouthpiece for his
child supposed voice of leadership in
society this is all completely backwards
and disordered in Rome and underneath
all of the the madness is a boy who just
needs his mom and dad to lend some
clarity amid confusion he's just
confused
and instead his ridiculous ineffectual
parents are more focused on following
cultural trends and being and being
fashionable than helping their child
become a well-adjusted human being but
don't worry because you know Wade and
his wife Gabrielle Union they they knew
they knew where to get information right
about how to parent their quote
transgender child his wife REIT reached
out to everybody on the cast of pose now
pose I look this up side never heard of
the show it is a queer musical dance
series that's a quote from an article so
not to fears I am mom and dad are
consulting with a queer musical dance
series to find out how to parent you
of course you've got Ellen sitting there
nodding like this is this is all great I
just makes a lot of sense the Train
seals in the audience clapping
it would be funny if it were not so
psychotic and sickening and if it
weren't actual children if there weren't
actual children being destroyed by this
unfettered raving left-wing lunacy so
it's it's but it will never stop being
shocking you know we can't get to a
point where we're used to this sort of
thing
and isn't it interesting by the way
isn't it isn't it what a coincidence
that it seems like the parents
who are who have bought into left-wing
gender theory
they're the ones who so often seem to be
the ones giving birth to daughters
trapped in boy bodies is that in that
fascinating but what a strange
scientific phenomena you've got all
these women especially in Hollywood who
have already bought into this craziness
and then they happen to be the ones who
give birth to the it just so happens
that all of their daughters are trapped
in boy bodies what do you know just a
coincidence I mean it couldn't possibly
be right that they are brainwashed
themselves the parents into this cult of
left-wing gender theory and so then
they're brainwashing their children it
couldn't possibly be that could it I
mean it could possibly be that that that
Zayas parents have been wasting this on
on him
that he's grown up in an environment of
confusion it hasn't gotten the the
direction and leadership that he needs
I mean you could possibly be that he's
growing up in a household where he's
told that gender you know gender is
fluid you could be whatever you want
nothing means anything the fact that
you're a boy biologically means nothing
whatsoever he's told that from birth
then what do you know at 12 he's saying
he's a girl couldn't be that the best
possible explanation for this is that
mystically supernaturally in some way
nobody can explain girls are really
being born in boy bodies that's the best
explanation obviously right
alright checking in with our friends
over it's Tommy John's you know when it
comes to comfort down below there's
there's underwear and there's Tommy
John's the rival the revolutionary
clothing brand that's redefined comfort
for Americans everywhere including
myself to put it simply Tommy John's
doesn't give an F and when we say
doesn't give an F that means that they
give three s they don't just give one
half they give three fabric fit and
function which are the three things that
you want when it comes to when it comes
to clothing in general but especially
the clothing you wear under your
clothing Tommy John obsesses over every
every little detail and stitch by using
proprietary fabrics that perform like
nothing you've ever worn before
as a result Tommy John's men's and
women's underwear Sport a no wedgie
guarantee okay that's important
comfortable stay put wet waist bands a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft feather-light moisture wicking
breathable which is very important and
designed to move with you not against
you okay so they're not they're not
struggling you don't want you know what
your underwear be struggling against you
and fighting a fighting a battle against
you every every second of the day
so give three apps about your underwear
and upgrade with Tommy John's today
hurry - Tommy John dot-com / walls for
20% off your first order that's Tommy
John com / walls for 20% off Tommy John
dot-com / Walsh the feel-good story of
the of the week maybe you heard jussie
Smollett has been or juicy similar as
Dave Chappelle has
named him has been indicted on six
counts related to making up a hate crime
against himself which so it's nice to
see that smollett's attacker has finally
been brought to justice and I figured
I'd be the one millionth person to make
that joke
maybe there's a prize or something for
being number one million but this is
great and it will be interesting to me
to see how Smollett decides to play this
now I'm guessing I don't know I'm
guessing but he'll probably be offered a
deal to avoid jail maybe some community
service but avoid jail if he admits what
he did publicly and that really would be
punishment enough in many ways
considering the the utter public
humiliation it would entail humiliation
that he's already suffered of course
because almost everyone thinks he's a
joke but now he actually asked test to
face that humiliation honestly and it
would probably rule out him ever making
a comeback in Hollywood again after he
admits it or will he maintain his
innocence even to the point of doing a
few months in jail or a few weeks
probably so that you know he can still
claim that he's innocent he does his
time and that's it I wouldn't be
surprised to see him take that deal take
the gel if it were me at this point I
don't know I think I might take the jail
cell
because you're
way too much to the lie especially when
you consider I went back today or
yesterday after this news broke and I
watched the clip of that interview he
did shortly after making up the hate
crime where he started we broke down in
tears describing the incident and now
that looked fake as hell then I mean you
could tell he was acting overacting
because he's not a great actor as it
turns out but the fact that he did that
and he was lying well if he comes out
now and admits that he was that it was
that it was a lie he's going it will be
essentially the same as announcing I'm a
sociopath and I I'm thinking probably
rather just go to jail then do that
alright let me ask you guys about this
and I'm gonna
go to email in a second but I wanted to
mention this I want to get your opinion
actually my my son got home from school
talking about speaking of parenting okay
my son got home from school this isn't
going to a transgender direction just
you know we do a homeschool co-op so two
days a week he goes into basically a
normal sort of school environment and so
well I got home yesterday after after
the kids and I go upstairs to my room
and I find my my son they're sitting in
a corner coloring by himself and he's a
really social upbeat kid most of the
time so I knew that something was up
I was talking to him and it took him a
while but he finally admitted that a kid
was teasing him in school today
the kid was apparently rhyming my son's
name in insulting ways which for a
six-year-old you know that amounts to
shots fired now he told me that this kid
was rhyming his first name and his last
name and I was trying to get my son to
tell me well what were the Rhymes
because okay I know my son's first name
there are some rhymes there but Walsh
what did he come up with for Walsh I
went to school public school for for 13
years
you know K through 12 and I no one was
ever able to come up with an insulting
less insulting nickname attached to my
last name now first name Matt you know
of course he got fat Matt fortunately I
was pretty skinny so that never really
worked out I don't really have a rat fit
I am ugly but I don't have a rat face so
they couldn't do rat man so and I kind
of escaped and then Walsh where do you
go with Walsh what rhymes with it I had
one kid in in sixth grade who tried to
get mouthwash going for Matt Walsh just
didn't catch on that's that's a stretch
Ben work so I don't know what they what
this kid was doing but he thought of
something and so I asked my son what the
other kid's name was and I'm not gonna
say it here because I don't really want
to publicly shame a six-year-old but it
was a name ripe for rhyming ripe for it
so I gave my son some ideas for rhymes
for insulting rhymes that he could throw
back and that kids face next time
and we sat for a minute breaths
brainstorming and my son thought that my
suggestions were hysterical I have to
say sorry they did impress a
six-year-old and so yes III did the the
upshot here is I did help my
six-year-old son come up with insults to
use against a fellow six-year-old at
school that did happen I admit am i a
horrible parent for that I may be a
horrible parent in general but is it
does it have anything to do with that
particular moment and here's here's
here's my justification first of all I
think that name rhyming and self defense
is ethical and I also think on a more
serious note if I'm gonna be really
honest and maybe I'm being more honest
than I should be I I actually don't
believe in the be the bigger person
stuff
I probably won't surprise you actually
but I don't I don't believe in it I
think that's a whole line that we tell
ourselves and our kids and I think it's
a lie we all know it's a lie all of us
know it all of us know here's why we
know it's a lie we say be the bigger
person right it seems like what most
parents say it's what they say in
schools kids insulting you be the bigger
person walk away tell an adult bigger
person well all of us know we went to
school and we still exist in society
society today even as adults we
encounter his bullying takes different
forms as an adult but you still sort of
deal with it sometimes someone who's
coming at you and in a certain way we
know that 99% of the time when when
you're when you're being the quote
bigger person responding to an insult by
not fighting back by by not by by not
throwing an insult back in that
direction when you're being the bigger
person it's because you're scared and
you're being timid it has nothing to do
with being bigger it's actually the
opposite you're being tiny you're being
the small tiny thing shrieking shrinking
away from the the confrontation bigger
person is a lie we tell ourselves and I
believe we all know that I think if you
looked in your own life at the times
when you are being insulted or attacked
in some way and you didn't respond if
you're being really honest with yourself
the reason you didn't you might bigger
bigger person is what you tell yourself
later after the fact in the moment
you're just scared and you're being non
confrontational and you don't want to
get into it that's the reason so I think
it's
teach our kids that when someone insults
them throw it back at them when they
come at you come back at them stand your
ground don't be afraid we make a mistake
I believe when we tell our kids stuff
like never insult anyone when they
insult you
that's it never never respond okay it's
don't don't be don't be small like that
don't do that
sticks and stones actually words do hurt
especially for kids and times when
you're insulted and torn down times when
someone belittles you to your face and
you don't respond those moments can
haunt you for life even if they happen
when you're a kid and we all know that
and yet we still say this bullcrap to
kids about this these things we know are
not true because we experienced it and
we still say it I don't know why we do
now I'm not saying this thing to half of
my son is gonna haunt him I know this is
a small thing right I know this is not
make try to make a big deal out of it
but it's a small thing but it's only big
in the sense of I want to instill in him
from an early age an attitude of I'm not
I'm not looking for trouble I'm not
being a bully but I'm gonna stand up for
myself if you punch me I'm gonna punch
back if you insult me I'm gonna throw
something back at you that's it we're
not being malicious and I try to hurt
your feelings but it's a fair's fair
that's how you get respect especially as
a boy I think it's a very good chance
you know some of my best friendships
happened in a situation like that some
of my best friendship especially in in
as a kid began with insults somebody
insults you you insult back and now
there's a respect so that's my thought
and this policy that every school has it
doesn't matter who started it
that is such BS so that's one of my
primary gripes about schools honestly
where they say it doesn't matter get
into a fight doesn't matter who started
course it matters who started it we say
that he started it is not a good excuse
of course it's a good excuse it's a very
good excuse if some kid is minding his
own business and another kid comes up
and starts something and the first kid
responds why in the hell should the
first kid get in trouble how is that not
a good
use the only other option is to run away
and be a tattletale
is that courageous is that really more
mature it's not gonna get you any
respect it's just gonna make it worse
another thing people have said to me I
was talking about this online and there
were some people saying well no the
right thing to do with bullies when they
insult you is to is to play along with
it and even throw some additional
insults at yourself and that will disarm
them they'll disarm the bully they won't
know what to do no please don't tell
your kids nonsense like that don't tell
them that it's not it that actually does
not work have you ever seen that work in
real life not in the movies I'm talking
about real bullies I'm not not talking
about bullies like in a Christmas story
where you've got a you know the tall
lanky freckled kid and his and his uh
his little henchman hanging out by the
fence
stealing lunch money hey you dweebs get
over here that kind of bully no that's
not that's not real life that's that's
movies from the 80s I'm talking about in
real life have you ever seen a real life
situation where kids being bullied and
he gets out of it by insulting himself
or being submissive being being
submissive and a good-humoured kind of
way no doesn't work just makes it was so
much worse bully would love that for you
to play along with it'd be hilarious I
actually did I remember distinctly when
I was a kid I saw another kid try that
strategy I witnessed it and it was a
disaster it it was it did not work out
well it became very awkward for the kid
worse than it was to begin with
and he walked away with his tail between
his legs
with telling our kids to you know defend
themselves and and demand some respect
yeah you have to demand respect to live
here you're not gonna get it an act that
goes for kids to it can be very damaging
for a kid at a young sailor they're very
young now it doesn't matter but
especially when they're young if they
get into the habit of being submissive
and shrinking away from confrontation
it's difficult to ever break that habit
they then might that'll set in and they
might be like that for the rest of their
lives
now one other thing we talk about being
the bigger person let me tell you what
being a bigger person is like this will
this would be a bigger person scenario
let's say there's somebody who's who is
a an MMA fighter okay it's strong and
bigger can fight could beat the crap out
of pretty much anyone especially people
who don't know how to fight and let's
say some little punk comes up to him at
a bar or something and smacks him in the
face and the guy the MMA fighter decides
not knows he could beat the hell out of
this guy decides not to that would be
the bigger person because that's coming
from a place of strength you know you
could do it you're definitely not afraid
of this guy but your head you're being
merciful and your what you're saying to
the other guys you know you're not even
worth my time you're such a little punk
I could rip you to shreds I'm not going
to and because I am merciful I'm not
gonna that is being the bigger person
but as I said 99% of the time when
someone is insulted punched or whatever
and the person who's who got insulted or
got punched doesn't respond 99% of the
time they're not being big they're being
scared
and so when you tell your kid be the
bigger person don't respond what your
matter what you think you're saying what
you're really telling them is be scared
be a wimp run away that's what you're
actually teaching them and you know it
and we all know because you've
experienced that we all have alright
let's move on to do some emails first of
all before we get there it's been a
crazy year so far and the election race
hasn't even started yet really hasn't
started in earnest especially the
general election it's hard to it's hard
to think that that's the case but it is
the best way to stay informed and to
stay on top of everything is to become a
daily water member with 20% off your
membership this promotion will be going
away soon so join now before it's too
late that is 20% off all daily by our
memberships when using promo code DW
2020 members get our articles add free
access to all of our live broadcast the
full three hours of Ben Shapiro every
day select bonus content access to the
mailbag Ben Shapiro's election insight a
PEZ plus our all-new all-access tier
which which includes the Q&A discussions
with me and Ben Shapiro and Clavin doles
some of the other writers I mentioned
yesterday I'm gonna be doing the Q&A on
Friday I'll be doing a Valentine's Day
Q&A I'm not sure why they came to me to
be the guy doing the Valentine's Day Q&A
but they did so I'll be doing that and
you could do all that if you're a member
and again if you want 20% off your
membership you have to act now before it
goes away that's promo code DW 2024 20%
off trust me you don't want to miss this
couple of emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from Marcus Matt he says Matt
you wrote that it would be a tragic
farce if America elects a communist
thirty years after winning the Cold War
well America won world war two and then
elected a Nazi in 2016 isn't that a
tragic farce too
you know Marcus I did write that this
morning your email I have no idea if
you're joking or not that's where we are
right now in our society I have no clue
if that's a joke I would hope that it is
and given that you're emailing me I
would think that it is because if you're
in the Trump is a literal Nazi camp I
doubt you'd be listening to my show not
that this is a show of constant Trump
boosterism by any stretch of the
imagination but still so I don't know
but then again a lot of people really do
feel oh sorry assuming for a moment that
you mean that seriously let me engage
with it and if you don't then plenty of
other people do when I say that it will
be a tragic farce some thirty years
after the Cold War to elect a communist
if that's if we elect Bernie Sanders
that's because it would be it's the kind
of thing that historians let me think
about that you've got this decades-long
struggle with communism America wins a
few decades later elects a communist to
run their country that's the kind of
thing historians for centuries to come
we'll be looking at and and researching
and trying to understand I books will be
written about it entire libraries on
that subject I don't think we even
understand how significant of a of a
title shift that would be in the history
of human civilization
really
and when I call Sanders a communist it's
because he is I don't mean it in a in a
general pejorative kind of way I mean he
really is a communist he's a he might
not use that word to describe himself he
does use socialist he may not say
communism communist but that's his
ideology and he's been very open about
it even recently but especially in the
past talking about how most major
industries should be the controlled by
the government okay
communism that's what it is now when you
call Trump a Nazi that work this is a
theme I always talk about right words
have meaning the word Nazi means
something and so you just sounds stupid
everyone sounds stupid when they call
Trump a Nazi Nazi is not a stand-in for
bad guy Nazis were bad guys but what
made them Nazis was not simply that they
were bad guys
particular ideology and a certain agenda
and so Nazis actual Nazis will be people
that were members of the National
Socialist Party in Nazi Germany or if
you want to say people today who are
openly sympathetic to their ideology and
their agenda and who are supporting it
and trying to enact it whatever you want
to say about Trump you could say Trump
is the worst president history you could
say is the worst person in history you
could say that he's worse than Hitler
that still doesn't make him a Nazi
the sibling incorrect label
so not a dictator as much as you might
not like him not a dictator
because those words means something and
he's not that so
maybe expand your vocabulary and find
another word to use to express your view
that Trump is a horrible guy
you could just say horrible guy we all
know what you mean but when you say not
see you you automatically lose the
argument because you're factually wrong
we'll go to Nathan says from Nathan I'm
a big fan and watch your show every day
halfway through your show yesterday you
talked about how many people including
Christians have an impulse to say that
we're living in the end times and that
the apocalypse is upon us
I agree of course that climate change
activists are pretty crazy and out of
line with their claims about doomsday
however as Christians isn't isn't it
healthy for us to do as Christians said
as Jesus said in that we should be
watching and waiting expecting his
return I'll admit many Christians go
overboard with this but nonetheless
shouldn't we as Christians be looking
for signs of the times especially in
regards to Bible prophecy I would love
to hear your perspective on this and ask
an eschatology in general keep up the
good work well I think Jesus told us to
be morally vigilant in the sense of not
allowing ourselves to fall into sin and
complacency but the point there the
point of Jesus made is that the Son of
Man will come like a thief in the night
you're not expected you're not gonna
know it you won't see it coming it will
just happen and that's how death will
also happen for all of us whether or not
we're around to see the end of the world
either way our end will come unexpected
as far as looking for signs of the end
of the world I think that's exactly what
we're not supposed to be doing no man
will know the day or hour an adulterous
generation looks for a sign I mean I
mean Christians have been looking for
signs of the end times and believing
they found those signs for 2,000 years
from the very first Paul addresses it in
his letters that were written in the
year 40 between 40 and 60 so right away
people were looking for the end and
thought that they were at the end and
there had been confident predictions of
the apocalypse ever since
Christian history is littered with them
and they've all failed to pan out in
spite of the fact that previous
generations have had many better reasons
to think they were living in the end
times think of the generation that lived
through two world wars in a span of just
a few decades or the various epidemics
that have wiped out millions across the
globe or think of earlier times with
more localized destruction and mayhem
may as well have been global because
nobody knew what was going on outside of
their own sphere think of a 16th century
when Europeans were landing in the new
world and there was this clash of
civilizations and they probably felt
that this
they were at the end of history
basically that the final piece of the
puzzle was filled in you could hardly
blame them for thinking that but here we
are you know five hundred years later
the world still going strong
maybe not strong but it's going so at a
certain point should we catch on a
certain point maybe after 2,000 years we
might say okay maybe we'll just stop
with this and live our lives and you
know it happens when it happens besides
have you actually read the prophetic
books of the Bible revelation Daniel
they're very abstract heavily
metaphorical which means you could
easily find references in them to modern
times but every generation in history
has been able to do that every
generation has been able to find
references to their modern times to
their contemporary times in these books
because the meaning is so much buried
under this difficult to decipher imagery
and nobody knows exactly what it means
I always there's a there's a strand of
Christianity that really holds
revelation you know as as as this
central crucial text which I'm not
saying it isn't a crucial text but in
the sense that they they believe they
can decipher it and that we should try
to do that I don't look at revelation
that way and I think clearly
I think clearly 2,000 years of history
proves that it's not that well I don't
know exactly what it is or what it means
nobody does so I think a revelation is
interesting I think it's
the imagery is sometimes beautiful
sometimes terrifying sometimes
bewildering sometimes confusing but
sometimes bizarre right so it's
interesting to read but that's kind of
as far as we can go with it
and beyond that if you're telling me you
understand everything it says then I'm
gonna have to think you know you're a
charlatan not you specifically no you're
not but people who say that are
charlatans all right
let's see
one last one from david says let me
preface this by saying that I think the
left's gender ideology is extremely
radical and that men and women are
different I keep seeing you ask the left
for a coherent definition of what it
means for a boy to feel like a girl
quote unquote and to define the word
woman etc but let me ask you I agree
with you that men and women are
different so can you please explain why
it is not possible for a boy to feel
like a girl the way I see it there are
two options either men and women are not
different in which case a boy feeling
like a girl makes no sense or men and
with women men and women are different
in which case a boy may in fact feel
like a girl whatever that may mean
thanks love the show well David I think
that sense boys and girls are different
that is precisely why the statement he
feels like a girl has no meaning what is
a girl feeling what do you mean that
someone feels like a girl
well the only thing that that can mean
alright well it could mean one of two
things one it could mean simply that he
has certain traditionally feminine
inclinations or proclivities or
character traits but a boy who has
feminine traits is just a boy with
feminine traits it doesn't mean he
actually is a girl and the left the left
must agree with that that it doesn't
mean he's a girl because they're the
ones who say that our ideas of
masculinity and femininity are
artificial and socially constructed so
you can't say that someone's
traditionally feminine proclivities mean
anything at all in fact the word
feminine according to the people that
espouse gender theory the word feminine
has no actual meaning itself it's
totally decided by Society so you can't
really tie it to that and if we now say
that men with feminine traits are women
then we are saying that women must by
definition be feminine we're not
allowing women to be anything other than
feminine because we're saying that to be
feminine is to be a woman which means to
be a woman is to be feminine but the
left doesn't want to say that so this
whole lot of argument is gone what's
next well what else could a woman
feeling mean it must then mean
woman feelings are feelings that women
have very simple that must be the
definition of a woman feeling or feeling
like a woman
what is feeling like a woman means it
means that you're a woman feeling to
feel like a woman is to be a woman who
feels what by definition men cannot have
women feelings because they're not women
the very fact that they're men having
the feeling is proof enough that these
are not women feelings and at any rate
the man would have no way of knowing it
was a woman feeling because he hasn't
been a woman in order to compare the
feelings so how could he possibly know
that that's how women feel he couldn't
comes circular
how do we know that he's a woman because
he has woman feelings how do we know
their woman feelings because he's a
woman you see its circular and this
isn't a valid way of thinking it's it's
it's inherently illogical it's
illegitimate and that's the issue with
it alright but thanks for the the email
I appreciate you know in conservative
listeners email me as they often do
trying to do the left a favor by making
some kind of sense out of their gender
theory it's oh I get so many of these
emails from conservatives saying you
know I think this is nonsense but maybe
what they mean is this so you're trying
to do them a favor but I think we have
to accept that no this is really totally
crazy and incoherent and there's no way
to make sense of it it contradicts
itself and you can't do it
but I think it's a noble attempt anyway
and thank you for that have a great day
everybody Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hay supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Sterling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me
Andrew cliff
[Music]